I
our next speaker is Hans acryl and he is
going to talk about how to make
using elastic search he is a pattern
developer and one of the core
contributors to django so let's welcome
bonza thank you so hello it's been as
it's been said my my name is on Sakhalin
I actually worked for the company behind
elasticsearch it's a it's a startup that
provides support and training if in case
you have you ever neat one so let's get
started with what actually elasticsearch
is or what what it what it tries to do
my goal in this talk would be to explain
a little bit what it can do and show you
how it is done behind the scenes so you
can sort of judge for yourself what it
would be good for and what where you
would probably use something something
else instead or in addition so what else
exert actually is is a distributed
search engine so if we if we take it
word by word it's distributed which
means that it's actually fully clustered
if you download elastic search and you
run it a very easy process all you need
is have Java installed and then it will
it will start automatically and you run
it twice the two instances will find
each other and they'll form a cluster
and they'll start sharing data that's
really all that is required so as long
as they're on the same network by
default they will start talking to each
other it's a very good way how to steal
data from others on conferences just
open your notebook with your elastic
search running with the default
configuration and you will get half of
the data from everybody else who has the
same configuration so this is very good
for development and it allows you to get
get up and running very quickly and sort
of play play with it but it's really not
recommended in production for obvious
reasons so make sure to be aware that
are then distributed it's it's an open
source product it's apache license so so
there's no problems there it's it's
document-based it uses leucine as its
engine as its core sort of to do most of
the heavy lifting the indexing and some
of some of the storage and it uses a
HTTP and json for pretty much everything
that it that it does so it's very it's
very flexible so it's document based so
it can index and work with anything that
that you can express as a as a JSON
document the JSON document can be nested
so you can have documents within
documents or Jason objects within Jason
objects you can have lists and
everything it's not exactly it
schema-less but it's it has dynamic
schema so you don't have to define the
schema before you start putting data in
we will sort of infer the type from the
data as we see it so the first time that
we see a field that we haven't seen
before or we haven't been informed
previously what it should be we look at
it and we take a guess does this look
like a number does this look like a date
if so we will we will annotate it
properly if not the fallback is always
always a string it does support some
relationships between documents you it's
not it's not isolated only to work on a
single document the two types of
relationships are nested and
parent-child nested is for the situation
where you have inner objects that should
have a citizenship status on their own
for example if you have a blog post and
comments so you're in a search on the
comments maybe but there are still part
of the block-post the parent-child
relationship is then for more
independent documents that are not part
of one document but have some one to
many relationship for example I'll be
using a stack overflow for some of my
demos I use the question and the answers
on Stack Overflow to model the
parent-child relationship so the
question is the parent and then the
answers are
children so you can query for questions
by specifying what the answer should be
so this is this is what an example
document would look like it's as I said
any any Jason any JSON document this is
a real-life question from Stack Overflow
stack overflow is very nice that it
provides all the data for download with
a Creative Commons license i believe so
you can see that the classical suspects
like title and body you also see the
commons which are in this case would be
the nested documents and you can
immediately see that you can we can
support both individual values as well
as arrays and lists and an inner objects
in fact there is actually no distinction
for us whether a field has a single
value or multiple values you can use
them sort of interchangeably so that's
sort of the the document model or the
data model so what can you do with the
data once you have them in elastic
search well the first answer is sort of
obvious right if a product gets called
elastic search probably it will do
search and it actually does the more
interesting part is the unstructured
search the full text search where we can
actually take text in individual fields
or across all fields and do up do a
proper full-text searching so we can do
everything from stemming and all this
all this complicated stuff so if you
have basically anything that you would
expect from a full text full text search
engine we can do phrase searches we can
do fuzzy searches we have we have asked
an API if you want to actually access
all the data that were result of a query
that sort of the first first use case
how many many of the data science people
would use elastic search is they would
use the they would use the query API and
the Search API to limit the rid the
result set to limit the data set and
then unload it all from us
search so let's say that you have a 100
terabyte of data that you want to that
you want to process but you're only
interested in always in some chunk of
the data elasticsearch then we'll
provide you with the functionality of
defining the criteria for the subset
that you're interested in and just
loading it all into into memory or into
into Python and do with it whatever some
more complicated analysis that elastic
search is not equipped to deal with so
the full-text search actually relies
heavily on analysis which is a process
of the text coming in and we need to
analyze it sort of to make it into a
canonical format that we can then search
on this analysis process includes simple
things like lower casing and also fairly
complicated things like stemming and it
essentially boils down to we have a text
on the input and a list of tokens on the
output and while this is a problem
that's fairly easy and well-understood
for example for English or for most
European languages it's something that's
very difficult for example for a lot of
the lot of the Asian languages that
don't necessarily even have a white
space so how do you even split it into
words how do you deal with things being
typed in different script so this is all
something that that leucine has leucine
has covered and we sort of tap into that
too to make that happen so that's one
type of the search the more the more
interesting one but also more esoteric
the other one that we are all probably
more familiar with is a structured
search or filtering in a gnostic search
those are for exact matches ranges geo
filters and everything and while a query
will give you not only the documents
that match but also information how well
the documents match so for example this
this document matches very well because
it has the search term in the title and
also in the body
filters will do none of those things it
will just limit the result set and
because they're much simpler they're
also much faster and because of the
underlying implementation their actual
cashable the way this works internally
is after a filter gets evaluated so we
get a list of documents that would match
your filter we essentially store this
information in form of a bit set so a
bit set is really what it sounds like
it's one bit per document because we
store documents in in a predictable
fashion and we never change the order we
can we can address them just by using a
position in a bit set so we can very
easily have a data structure that's
super small like one bit per document
how more efficient can you get and super
easy to work with for example if you
want to combine multiple filters and you
have two bit set that's a bitwise
operation that's something probably the
most effective operation you can do on a
cpu so it's very nice for it for this
reasons and this also enables us to
cache individual core filters so the
individual conditions and then always
combine them together from the caches so
if you have ten filters in your query
and only one of them keeps changing you
will always reuse the nine remaining
caches so this is something that makes
that makes our filtering very very fast
and very efficient we'll see hopefully
examples later if if we if we don't run
out of time so the last thing that that
we can do as part of as part of sort of
a search is we have a bunch of tools
that we go to jesters I separated them
into into two groups one is a terms or a
phrase suggester and that's the
functionality that everybody knows by
the did you mean if you type something
into Google and and you you make a typo
or or it's not as common
Google will try to suggest you something
and that's what what term or phrase
suggester is the difference between
those two is the context awareness
whereas a term suggester can find typos
in individual words phrase suggester can
even find correction even phrases where
all the words are correctly typed but
don't match don't make sense together my
favorite example for this if you try to
search for Johnnie Walker the whiskey
and you specify jenius Joh nny you won't
find anything because with the whiskey
johnny is actually spelled with an IE at
the end so term spell checker will not
find it because it's still a correct
version of how you can spell Johnny but
a fresa gesture will actually catch
catch it and say hey did you actually
mean the whiskey so those those are the
phrase adjusters and the completion
suggester is something for auto complete
it's super fast because it was designed
that it should be executed on a simple
keystroke so whenever a user is typing
something in you can keep running the
autocomplete suggester and ask every
single every single time for auto
completion in this case fast for us
means a sub millisecond response times
so you can literally do the completion
on each East rogue to help people
facilitate this the only I'm not sure
whether its downside but it's certainly
an important characteristic is you need
to supply the score yourself because we
are not able to say like on this one one
letter how well does this word match
that's an information that that has no
meaning so you need to suit the possible
suggestions manually basically on based
on your business logic so this is what
we can do in terms of searching and
filtering we support all ranges of
operation like ranges matches exact
matches fuzzing matches geo matches so
you can limit something to an area or
something like
at and now let's look a little bit on on
how its implemented so a full-text
search or searching through information
is a fairly old problem it was first
solved in in this 13th century it's one
of the one of the oldest data structures
out there and the data structure is is
called an inverted index you're all very
familiar with this because whenever you
read any any sort of scientific book or
anything at the end there was an index
that's exactly this it's a list of terms
with pointers to documents in which they
appear with some metadata in case of a
book it's a list of terms sorted
alphabetically with a set of pages where
those terms occur so this is an example
of one such inverted index you can see
that we've inverted a forfeit we've
index for files file 1 2 through 4 that
deal with Django flask some jazz music
in there and we've essentially found all
the words in the documents sorted them
and then for each we have a list of
files in which they occur again sorted
so now when we actually want to execute
a search so let's say that we want to
search for python and django that's
super easy we just locate the two words
on left and we have two sorted lists
that we now have to merge so we just
woke those two walk those two lists and
whenever we see the same document that's
our result so as you can see it's very
effective mechanism because it's just
merging sorted lists and it is one other
important characteristic is its not
limited to just using one index you can
very easy
get these lists from multiple indices at
the same time in fact that's how it
that's how it always works because this
data structure while it's pretty
straightforward to build it's super hard
to actually update so most of the search
engines don't update they'll just create
a set of inverted indices like that and
then when they query they will query
query across them all at that point in
just one more step to make it
distributed over a network so you can
immediately see that you can get the
sorted lists from as many indices as you
can which means that when you search
with elastic search or when you filter
you're always only hitting the index and
you're hitting an index on every single
field that you're querying there is no
such thing as a as a full table scan we
never actually go to the document so
that's something to something to keep in
mind that's again one thing one little
trick that keeps us fairly optimal and
of course this is a data structure that
lends itself to a lot of improvement for
example if we just mark the positions of
the words in the files as part of as
part of this list we can now do a phrase
search because if we were searching for
the phrase Python web it means that
we're looking for a file where putt the
word python is followed by the by the
word web so during the merging of these
two lists we just need to look at the
positions and detect when there is an
offset of one that's a phrase that means
that in that document there was the word
Python followed by the word web and we
can very easily make this more flexible
we can say for example that we allow two
or three words to be in bit windows and
so instead of just looking for a
difference of one we can be looking for
a difference of less than three so again
a very very powerful concept and
everything just works because we are in
the end just merging sorted lists which
is a very effective operation and
operation that can that lends itself
very well to distribution both in terms
of CPUs and in terms of of network so
it's easily distributable and it's also
very flexible again because of the fact
that I can query across multiple indices
at the same time I have a lot of freedom
in how do i structure my data how do I
manage them for example I can have an
index per day which makes everything
manageable like one day one day worth of
data is usually fairly fairly manageable
and typically I'm only interested in
today and then nothing is stopping me to
actually query across the entire week
I'll just square across seven indices I
don't care there is no penalty for
searching gross indices so that's really
a really powerful schema that you can
use to store a lot of data analysis
search that's one of the reasons why
elasticsearch is very popular for
storing log data Weather Machine logs or
any other logs log is essentially
anything with a with the timestamp so
you can you can use this to store
indices to store data every day and then
you just delete the old ones or remove
them or archive them or backup them and
you can keep going forwards and you can
grow every every day so this was
searching and how to actually get the
data that you want and that's really
great if you already know what you're
looking for if you just want to limit
something but this dollar has been about
exploration or should have should have
been it has an until now so let's let's
deal with that a little bit more so what
I want to talk about now is aggregations
aggregations is essentially any
operation where you take a group of
documents and you run some calculation
on them we just use the terminology of
metrics and buckets first we define
different buckets in in which we divide
the documents that we have and then
inside each bucket we run a metric so
buckets can be nested so you can you can
create a bucket per per year and then
inside each year you can create a bucket
for each category or buckets based on
range from from central London so
something like that and the metrics are
then our than the usual suspects like
numerical aggregation sense statistical
ones and also some some interesting
language things that we will that will
see later so some examples of how you
can define buckets in elastic search the
first one I've already mentioned you can
create a bucket per category or for
range of field you can use you can use
Geo data to actually do the same thing
so do do range based on distance from a
simple location or just create a grid
into which you want to divide your your
document you can do date histogram so
you can have daily buckets or monthly
and general things things like that
nothing nothing too surprising the only
important thing to keep in mind is that
you can nest those so you can create
multi-dimensional aggregations in a
single query that's a very powerful
concept that that takes a lot of people
a while to wrap their heads around so
and then the metrics that go inside
there are some very simple ones like
count which you will actually always get
you don't need to specify that some
average on a numerical field or even
minimum on a string field why not you
can do stats or extended stats which
will give you the basic statistical
indicators like standard deviation sum
of all squares and all this all this
stuff that I don't really understand
and also we have some very interesting
aggregations one of that one of them is
significant terms it will actually take
all the terms all the tokens all the
words from a field and it will give you
the ones that are specific or
significant for that bucket so what's a
specific tag for a certain category or
for a certain time period in other words
what's trending so you can actually see
immediately like what is what was
specific for for this bucket so for this
for this week what was the most commonly
used tag compared to all the others not
just in absolute values but
comparatively to two other buckets and
of course you can you can mix and match
those so you can nest the buckets then
create multiple then define multiple
metrics on on any of the any of the
levels and you can go as deep as as your
as your memory will allow this is all
calculated in one pass over the data in
near real time by near real-time I mean
milliseconds we'll see some examples
later so it's tens of milliseconds on
them unreasonable reasonable Hardware
this scale is actually pretty well we
have people running this in on data sets
in the size of tens and hundreds of
terabytes so how is this implemented
we've seen the inverted index and that's
really not a good data structure for for
this so for this we actually have a
different one we take the inverted index
and we uninvited so it's the field data
data structure and we call it the onion
verted inverted index because that's
always fun to say and there are two
different ways how you can actually how
you can actually use those by default we
will just when you first need this data
structure will uninvite the index and
load it all into memory
and that's obviously very fast once you
have it in memory but it obviously eats
a lot of memory there is there is
another option that's been added
recently to elasticsearch which we call
doc values and those actually reside on
disk so there are built at index time
and and are updated as you as you index
more documents or change the existing
ones and it's almost as fast as the
in-memory ones we are still working on
making it even faster currently in a
master master branch we can get it up to
forty percent slower that's that that's
the worst case scenario that we have
seen so far usually we are we are about
the same as the in-memory ones and in
some rare cases even faster so exciting
we are getting really really fast and
this is obviously not our invention this
is not something specific to
elasticsearch this is all how old column
stores actually work just store the
column together so that you can iterate
very quickly over all values for a
certain field for aggregations so in
this case we are very similar to any
other data store that that's geared
towards aggregations and analytics so
now we have all the tools we know how to
how to limit our our data set if we if
we know how we are limiting it we can
also we also know how to ask a las six
search actually to give us all the
possible limiting values just by using
aggregations so that that's the
exploration part so now let's see how
this typically fits together I've
prepared three examples two of them
simple and the third one will actually
be life coding so fingers crossed so the
first example at the most commonly
associated with search and with this
type of thing is faceted navigation when
you search a website let's say let's say
a website designed to actually store
code and you do a search
i'm using this example because yes get
up is actually using elastic search for
that and you type something in you get
the list of results in the middle that's
great but to me always the most useful
part is is this part on the left or you
can see the distribution across the
types of documents that are found and
some other categories in this case
languages and we can immediately see how
many how many documents how many objects
match in our case repositories fit into
each of these buckets so this is the
most important exploration part when you
search of for a hotel on booking.com
again an elastic search user you can
immediately see like what are the range
is what are the price ranges of the
hotels in the area that you selected and
you immediately know you don't have to
read through all the records to know if
they're there are any fancy hotels in
San Francisco under 100 bucks in case
you didn't know that before it's
immediately apparent from from the
facets from the results of the
aggregations so this is the first real
use case how people use aggregations and
search together you define your surge
you display the aggregation so that
people can narrow down the search and
zero in on what they want really quickly
even if they didn't know what their
options were previously of course you
could say that people could have written
like yeah i'm looking for something
starting with DJ and i wanted to be in
python but what if they didn't know that
django was written in python now they
know so that was one use case the other
use case is look analysis as i said a
lot of a lot of people use elastic
search to store logs we even have a
protocol log stash that will actually
facilitate that facilitate that that
process excuse me and also we have a
product called gabbana to visualize it
and Cabana is just an in-browser job
application so all you see is actually
calculated by elasticsearch itself and
just visualized by cabana so in this
example I'm searching through logs of an
HTTP server I have defined several
categories on how to break it down the
request for PHP files static HTML PNG
pictures CSS and and everything and we
can either look at the this is a result
of a terms aggregation or this is a date
histogram with a terms aggregation
inside so the nested multi-dimensional
aggregations so you can immediately see
and visualize you can see that there is
a weird drop here this is something that
would be very hard to just recognize
from just looking at the at the raw data
for that you need visualization and the
results of the aggregations actually
lend themselves very well to
visualizations especially if you can
find a way how to express the
multi-dimensional nature that the
aggregations can have with two
dimensions it's still fairly easy if you
add more it gets it gets hairy and and
you need to need to define a good
visualization to actually make use of it
and of course in cabana you can just
click on an individual field and just
see that see the distribution again the
exploration part where you where you
look at the extension field and you
immediately get the all the possible
extensions including some data like how
often is this extension how rare so this
is our this is our second use case for
analyzing logs and now wish me luck
so it shows for you okay can you read it
in the back or less okay so for this for
this example I've loaded the data set
from from stack overflow and we're going
to some some exploration to see what's
what's actually what's actually
happening so I'm starting with a very
simple very simple query I have a
filtered query and the only thing I'm
filtering is I'm interested in questions
that's actually part of the part of the
URL up here and I'm also interested only
in documents that have been created
after 2012 and I have two aggregations
defined I have a terms aggregation
define on the field tags that I that I
call tags and I have a frequency
aggregation which is a of a type date
histogram over the field of creation
date and the precision or the interval
is month so now i can i can execute this
and see see the results so in total it
was just twelve thousand hits and i can
see i can see the buckets so the most
common tag on programmer stack exchange
of org is is java people apparently have
the most problems and questions about
Java C sharp is the second one and so on
and so forth and we can see the
distribution of the questions per tag if
we scroll down a little bit we see the
same for month so nothing nothing too
surprising we could very easily take
these numbers and visualize it in in
some form of line to see sort of the
distribution over month and to look for
any spikes or maybe plug down the
expected expected traffic
as we as we see any any trend so that's
that's the first part now let's let's
get something a little bit more
interesting so we have the same thing
except I added one more one more nested
aggregation now i'm looking for average
comment count per tag so i still have I
still have the buckets per tag so again
you see Java on the first place nothing
has changed but here there is one new
information there is an average over a
numerical field that we have in our data
a common count so we can see that Java
has by average almost for almost four
comment any question on Stack Overflow
for java as almost 4 comments and that
was just us getting started so in this
example we can we can see again we are
starting with the with the same thing we
district we create buckets / tags where
we are interested in the comment average
per each bridge bucket for each tag and
then also what we are interested for per
each tag is aggregation aggregating over
comments and I I told you in the
beginning that I model this that Commons
are essentially the nested document with
questions so I'm saying yeah I want to
aggregate over the nested documents and
I'm interested in top commenters which
is a terms aggregation over the field
owner display name I here used raw
because I don't want the analyzed
version of the of the display name I
don't want the stemmed lower cased
version i want the actual full value so
i'm using draw and then for each of
those for each of the people who were
one of the top 10 most commenters in
this field i want to see the maximum
score for a comment so when i run this
you can see that again nothing has
changed the most asked questions are
still tagged with Java there are still
nearly 4 comments per question which
makes sense because there is 3000 3000
comment and here are the top commenters
so the first person is called Nat and he
single-handedly route 92 comments for
questions tagged with Java and the best
comment for a question for a best sorry
best score for a common that he wrote
for java was 7 and if you if you scroll
down you can see you can see more people
and if you scroll even down you can see
it for different for different tags we
have limited ourselves to just the top
10 tags and in each tag only for the top
line commenters we could very easily
just get the entire grid the entire a
sort of multi dimensional cube and get
it all at get it all at once and if we
scroll willing really down will actually
see the same for four month it's part of
the query I haven't shown because it
looks very similar and here we can see
again in February 2012 there was 768
questions top with 2529 Commons and the
most person the most active commenter
was asked a lot with 116 comments with
the best score of 18 so with just one
pass over the data with a with an
operation that took you cannot see that
so I'll tell you it took 37 milliseconds
to actually run this on my machine and
it's the entire data set of programmers
at stack exchange at Oregon so this is
this is a definitely an interesting
interesting aggregation to to run to see
what's what's going on there and one
last that I have that I have prepared is
the significant terms aggregation and
also just just to make it more
interesting I also included percentiles
just essential show of that we have them
and this aggregation what it does if I
run it is again we are defining things
into into buckets in this case again per
month and you can see the result of the
of the other aggregation which is the
trending so sort of the significant tags
that were that are significant for this
month so we can see that for this month
it was java web development permissions
interview and you even get the number of
documents that match versus the number
in elsewhere and the score sort of the
the level of confidence we have in this
in this prediction there is a
complicated mathematical model behind
this which I don't even presume to
understand but it gives you some some
interesting data so again we can see for
the other month it changes the first
people are more interested in website
performance java web development
interview and stuff like that and this
is not what was what were the most
common terms in that bucket these are
what were the most significant compared
to compared to the other buckets and
sorry I lost my key note somewhere okay
so that's it from from my part and now
if you have if you have any questions
I'll be more than happy to answer them
thank you
yeah thank you so much for your talk
pretty insightful can you shed some
practices on loading data in terms of
batch for example we need to load data
which are in the range is about 60 to 70
million documents and looking forward to
load them in an asynchronous manner
because how I understand when I push a
document in elasticsearch it waits for
the response to come back from that side
so when we're doing it for 90 or 100
million documents how can I do it in
batch and in a civilized manner physical
so for fast loading there is a there is
a bulk API which allows you to bulk load
the documents currently our our record
speed that has been recorded somewhere
is one customer of ours I believe it was
a verizon broke the record at eight
gigabytes per second of indexing from so
they used a dupe cluster to run a
parallel job to actually start loading
data in parallel into elastic search for
that if you if if you already have a
Hadoop cluster we also have a Hadoop
integration that will that will actually
help you with that with that process so
overall it just use use bulk api's you
there are a lot of knobs that you can
tweak to make the indexing faster we're
actually currently working on a blog
post that you that should come up in the
next couple of weeks they'll deal
exactly with that like how to optimize
for load time thanks
Thank You right that was a very
interesting talk I have a question about
the the specifications that are needed
for the hardware to actually run the
elastic search do you have any resources
on the website about that like say you
want to load a hundred million documents
and each of those documents about 50k
then what would be the size of the
machine oh you would need for that okay
so the so the factor by which that the
data is is expanded differs a lot on
your settings and also on your data and
what you want to do with the data so for
example by default will take all the
string values from your document and
index them also together as sort of one
artificial feel that we call underscore
all and that that's used when you don't
specify a feel that you're searching on
if you just want to search across
everything that's easily turned off and
there are other things like this which
you can turn off also if you're not
interesting in doing full text search
you can just index the exact values and
not run an analysis so unfortunately
there is no no number i can i can tell
you what we what we recommend people is
try like you should you should see you
should see a clear linear progression
that should give you the ratio of the of
the index data versus the raw data and
then when whenever you tweak a setting
like this you can see you can see a
change and and everything so
unfortunately i don't have a good result
hi i would like to ask how big is your
index and if you are using dynamic
mappings I'm sorry helping is a how big
is they Nixon the demo example we had
and if you're using dynamic mappings so
that's a good question I don't know oh I
cannot show you anymore but uh
so the the index is approximately 200
megabytes in in memory uh no 300 300
megabytes on disk the raw data was like
200 200 megabytes and no i'm not using
dynamic mappings i'm using dynamic
mappings for some of the fields but for
most of the fields i I cared enough that
i actually created the mappings
beforehand as part of the as part of the
load script because for example by
default all the oldest stringfield's
would get analized so you couldn't do
aggregations on them or the aggregations
would make no sense for example if you
have a city and you have New York and
you analyze it will have new and York
separately so when you run aggregations
you would it the data would make no
sense whatsoever so in those cases you
actually have to supply your own
mappings make sense thank you hi my
question would be about suggestive word
and phrase like jesters and work from
what I understood you need to insert
them manually isn't it so does it mean
that what you need to implement it
yourself or how it really works no no
absolutely not so I actually have an
example I can show so you may even the
phrase registers
so this is my Johnnie Walker example so
I just index three documents with three
different names these is just using the
dynamic mapping so I'm not setting up
anything and then what i can do is
obviously it doesn't match anything on
the phrase Johnnie Walker but if I also
run the suggest I get bagged the
suggestion with wither with the correct
spelling so you can see that i haven't
had AI didn't have to set up anything i
just i just use it and the only thing
that I need to do is ask for a suggest
with some parameters but it's it's
defined in Queen query time I haven't I
haven't defined anything anything
beforehand so it would work also for
streets or something like that yeah
absolutely okay yeah thanks thank you
yeah so if anybody else has some
questions please feel free to ask on
south line and we get ready for the next
start now thank you once again
you
you